the united states and iran have been
arch enemies for decades now and once
again tensions are running high
the question is can the incoming biden
administration and the divided
leadership in tehran renegotiate the
nuclear agreement that donald
trump walked away from in 2018 and
at what price certainly a lot hinges on
what the two sides choose to do next
so here on to the point we ask iran and
america
is a new nuclear deal possible
[Music]
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on to the point where my guests
are saria sahadi nelson
a u.s iranian journalist based here in
berlin who says
any new iran nuclear deal that the biden
administration negotiates
will require concessions to tehran that
will hurt the president
at home also with us is cornelius adibar
from the german council on foreign
relations
his opinion the europeans need to seize
the moment to reinvigorate diplomacy
first on the nuclear file then on
regional security
and a very warm welcome to to daniel
gala editor-in-chief
of the middle east quarterly zenith who
argues that
the middle east needs a new framework
for security and cooperation
without this there will be no stability
thank you all three for those statements
a good start to the show and i'd like to
go
straight to soraya with the inevitable
question how tense is the relationship
between iran and the us right now well
it's pretty bad i mean it's it's been
many years since it's been this bad
although i would argue it's a little
better than it was on january 19th
before the new president came in because
it's very clear that
uh president joe biden would like to see
that changed he really wants to go back
to some sort of conversation with iran
and daniel daniel
let's just get technical for a moment
because last week the head of the
international atomic energy agency was
uh in tehran just a week ago that was a
very important uh
visit just explain why well it's
important because
iran has threatened let's say the
iranian indian parliament has also asked
for iran to suspend the control of this
international atomic agency and this is
of course
a violation not only of the iran nuclear
deal
but also of other non-proliferation
agreements
that iran has subscribed to
and so these negotiations were an
important signal
they were also an important signal
because some there is some sort of
international arrangement of
international mechanisms still alive
and of course the iranians know that
europe is nervous they know that the
americans are nervous they know that
everyone in the region is nervous
and they themselves have the problem
that the iranian government
doesn't want to give in to the pressure
of certain
hardline factions in the parliament that
dominate the parliament
and so they somehow want to show that
they're still
uh in control they're still in charge
and they're still willing
to negotiate so cornelius everybody's
talking about the prospect of a renewed
nuclear deal is it going to happen and
who needs it most
well the world needs it it's been a
remarkable achievement to have this kind
of an agreement
back in 2015 to set standards for
nuclear verification for what the
country can do
legitimately under the the international
conventions
um and so it would be bad if it was
simply
left to fade out as it were after the
departure of the united states and then
the subsequent
non-compliance with the iranians but the
window that has been opened by this
recent visit in tehran
the window of opportunity is short we
are speaking about three four months
uh max where we need to have some kind
of
an accord uh to reinstate the old uh
agreement and then go on to some
follow-on negotiations
um so this is really an issue of urgency
and when cornelius talks about the old
deal what he's talking about is the
jcpoa the joint comprehensive plan of
action
that was signed as we've seen back in
2015 back then barack obama was the u.s
president
and he called the deal a victory for
diplomacy
after years of tense negotiations the
u.s
the uk france russia china and germany
signed the nuclear agreement with iran
in 2015
in vienna in the treaty iran promised to
refrain from
any activity that could serve the
production of nuclear weapons
and agreed to have that checked in
return economic sanctions against the
country would be lifted
then in 2018 relations broke down
barack obama's successor donald trump
withdrew the u.s from the agreement
harsh sanctions against the islamic
republic followed
the result iran no longer feels bound to
the deal and is ramping up
uranium enrichment significantly now the
international inspector's monitoring of
the nuclear facilities
is set to be limited iran says it won't
return to its obligations under the
agreement
until the sanctions are lifted the deal
could be revived by the new u.s
administration under joe biden but it
wants to renegotiate the deal
something iran opposes how could such a
new agreement come about
well that's the big question isn't it i
suppose the the you could also say
one german newspaper that i saw they had
the headline is this the end of the road
for the nuclear deal
uh are you do you share that pessimism
danielle no i don't share it
um i think it is the deal was reasonable
and the deal can be uh implemented
it has proven successful to a certain
extent so i don't see any reason why one
wouldn't be able to return
to this deal the question is just like
is
is everyone willing to do so and the
other question is
um don't we create some like false
expectations when we think that
we could probably include other issues
of regional security
this is this is the problem this is the
point that joe biden has been making so
well he's he hasn't i think he's been a
bit uh willfully ambiguous about it
he hasn't said that he wants to include
uh for example the iranian missile
program
into this uh deal and i think he he he
knows very well why he didn't do so
his team of advisers are seasoned
diplomats people with experience in
negotiations and people with experience
in
iran negotiations establishment is back
to a certain extent yes of course and
they're being harshly criticized by the
republican camp
uh but uh in general i think they know
very well what the iranians uh are up to
and they know that the iranians would
not
that this is the kind of a red line to
include any other regional security
issues
into the nuclear deal and to be honest
uh they will be vindicated because even
the europeans
uh america's closest allies always said
this deal is about limiting or or
disenabling the iranian nuclear weapons
program
and it's not there to uh sort out or to
to create regional security arrangements
that should be done
in a i think in a different round of
negotiations and in a different format
in which the us should definitely not
take the lead
the the diplomats talk about the
choreography of all this how we get from
a to b to see wherever it is we're going
to be going wherever it is we want to be
tell us a little bit more about that
process
well that's that's something which which
cannot simply be done by the united
states and iran alone because both
countries have domestic politics uh
on this uh going on um and there is
pressure in the united states
from the republican camp uh but also
from uh hardliners within the democrats
headliners on both sides
each other and that's an interesting and
interesting observation
um and the same is true for iran i mean
one tends to take iran as a unitary
country you know the mullahs
on top ruling everything but behind this
scene of the facade there is real uh
power play going on between various
camps also inside iran
and as daniel galla was saying the the
parliament has has put out a demand
that the investors be kicked out and the
government has to somehow comply with it
and there was this arrangement uh being
done with the international atomic
energy agency
but what has to happen now is that um a
mediator like the european union would
have to lay out
over the next say two three months what
does each side
need to do in order to go back into
compliance so that at a point in the
future
before probably june both sides can
claim
at this particular moment in time we
have both come into uh into compliance
because they they have drawn their red
lines on this that sounds like
synchronicity that would be seventh
heaven for the diplomats but it's
that's not quite the way things are at
the moment i mean it's all a big
discussion about who's going to make the
first step who's going to make the first
concession well i think uh in terms of
who has the ability to do that i
i do think that rests with the americans
in the end it was the americans that
pulled out first
and sort of started this cascade and
secondly iran or the iranian government
currently is
is battling to stay in power that would
be the more moderate well whatever that
means nowadays faction
that's in charge there and um they have
elections coming up in june and there's
a lot of pressure behind
what's going to happen in the elections
that's going to have an impact on the
story we're trying to sort of
tell or understand here well there are a
lot of conservative leaders who
are sort of populist if you will where
they
there is some appeal to them even though
they are not exactly
what perhaps the younger generation is
looking for in terms of having more
freedoms that sort of thing but um they
are
sort of speaking to people's struggles
very real struggles in iran right now i
mean these sanctions
uh and the sanctions before them and the
sanctions before those have really
decimated uh the iranian economy i mean
there are a lot of
very educated young people who can't get
jobs uh and you know and they're unable
to leave although now
obviously the pressure has been lifted a
little bit on uh people getting visas to
get out of iran but um it's it's a real
struggle and
i don't rouhani has been a
disappointment you know he has a lot of
problems that uh that a
incumbent candidate and iran does
because there are some very real
problems there as mentioned
so um i i do think that in the case of
joe biden
if he were able to somehow finagle
something that brings both
parties to the table simultaneously that
that might help jump-start it but i
agree
um yes i was going to say i agree though
that we it can't be a multitude of
topics it really needs to focus on
getting
the deal going again or back on first
and then we can worry about all the
other stuff in different arrangements
allow me to jump in here because uh why
is it significant at the presidential
election you
you have the narrative on the one hand
that the supreme leader of iran
is not up for election he's going to
stay
so he's the one who takes the final
decision on
on on everything and of course in in in
the united states i often hear the
argument
it doesn't matter who is the president
because the supreme leader eventually
he's the
establishment of the islamic republic he
is the regime and therefore
he's the one who's going to take the
decision that's not very much like in my
view not the case because
the one who has to roll out the the the
the politics and the policy is the
president
of course the supreme leader has some
has a final decision and the national
security council does
but the president has to be uh has to
establish a cabinet he has to assemble a
team
to continue uh negotiations and to to to
design the foreign policy
so the role of the president is
extremely important i don't share the uh
the the view that it's all a game of
hardliners and conservatives in iran
for example rouhani has been branded the
rationalist camp
but he's the one he's the one who cares
about national security
he might be a rationalist a reformist
person in
certain aspects but after all he is the
guy for national security
he has a background in intelligence and
national security and defense and that's
his logic but that's what he cares about
and i think there is to a certain extent
a consensus
in iran uh regarding certain issues of
national and regional security
which is not regardless of if you are
conservative or if you are
hardline or reformist and therefore
rouhani was was elected
and though he might have been a
disappointment in terms of economic
reform
and and liberal reform i think he
delivered on the national security issue
i think that's one more reason to be you
know forceful
and and pressing for diplomacy now um
because
with this election there will certainly
be also a change of policy inside iran
obviously history doesn't repeat itself
and if so it does from tragedy to farce
but if you look at the iranian
negotiations and compare it to what
happened between 2003 and 2005 the
europeans had started these negotiations
the nuclear negotiations rouhani was
their counterpart
and then a new president was elected
ahmadinejad
many whom of us will remember as a fire
brand
and as a difficult negotiation partner
so what may happen just now again is
that
we are still in the space where dialogue
is possible where the iranian government
has said that they want
the nuclear deal to be reactivated um
but if we wait until after the election
with the new president and the irony
is that president ahmadinejad former
president may run again he's mulling
he's he's
he's making noises and then you'd have
trump on the other side basically oh
there we go or mike pompeo for the next
uh
presidential elections and then we're
really down the drain okay
one word that i haven't heard i i think
that i haven't heard from any of you so
far in the discussion and that surprises
me
is trust yeah the why does that mean
drastic the drastic absence of trust
between the two sides
how do you overcome that well again i
think the ball is in the american court
uh to to try and make an overture that
suggests
that not only will they come back to the
table in a way that
is respectful of of iran
not just telling it what to do and you
know carrying out hawkish policies but
also that shows some sort of lasting
effect because there is a great fear
what happens after four years 2024 is
around the corner
and it's not just the nuclear deal that
you know where new provisions uh have to
be drawn but it's also
you know potentially another republican
president and not just any republican
president it could be donald trump
mike pompeo is that what you suggested
anything's possible i guess but um
there's also been a a a lack of trust on
the side uh in the iranians i would like
to say i mean the europeans
who shepherded this this deal in 2015
they really thought that
once the deal is in place one can tackle
these other issues regional
security issues but iran had none of
that they they were
expanding in the region obliging by the
nuclear deal but doing anything else
that was in their own interest
regional wise and so the europeans are
disappointed with the iranians
vice versa the iranians would have hoped
that the europeans had
much more of a backbone when it came to
u.s sanctions so
we didn't mention trust because it's not
there i would simply say and that's why
it's also important to to to salvage the
deal as much as it's there to build from
that
basis again ironically i disagree here i
don't think it's a lack of trust
i think that trust is being
overestimated in this whole game and for
for the
following reason if you look at the
iranian
diplomatic and governmental
establishment like foremost of course uh
foreign
you see the way that he commands
diplomacy a mix of
being sometimes a bit bullish sometimes
being rather
like playing the the seducing card so
they command like all colors of
diplomacy that that that
like in a very old-fashioned style um
but they always think that the west
knows our true intentions which is why
would we use a nuclear weapon against
our neighbors we're just doing this to
defend ourselves because we are being
attacked
they know that uh much of what we say is
to create bargain chips and
and rhetoric and they underestimate the
true fear
and the way the misreading of the
supposedly true intentions of iran on
the western side
the iranians very often this is quite
interesting because because many of the
iranian
leaders have studied in the west they
know western society very well but they
underestimate to what extent the
regional neighbors the israelis
even some europeans and americans are
truly afraid
of the iranian intentions and that is
israel is not going to let anybody
underestimate the level of fear that is
felt
in israel netanyahu's mantra
of course we have we have uh people in
the israeli security establishment who
know very well who were
asking for a swift return to the nuclear
deal and they were
they've been advocates of the deal
before the climate between
uh washington and jerusalem or tel aviv
is at the moment not the best because
the us government very well remembers uh
like the very disloyal
uh demeanor of benjamin netanyahu in the
last years or the last days of the
obama biden administration so they're
not on very good terms at the moment but
at the same time they have
they're pragmatic and reasonable and
they know that israel on the one hand
could benefit from a nuclear deal but of
course it wouldn't solve
any of the regional issues that israel
is is involved in and exposed to
okay well iran certainly seems to be
facing more uncertainty but one thing
is for sure the sanctions and the covet
crisis
are together having a devastating impact
on the people of iran
ever since the u.s placed sanctions on
iran
its economy has shrunk at least five
percent every year
oil production the country's most
important source of revenue
has almost completely stalled as has its
banking sector
many european companies have also been
pulling back for fear of reprisals from
the u.s
the result prices have been skyrocketing
and iran's inflation rate is currently
around
30 percent those suffering most are the
iranian people
many hope a resumption of negotiations
with the west will help bring
improvements
people have been living under severe
economic pressure
and if they want to cut off cooperation
that pressure will of course intensify
the problems have become so huge that
people can't even live a normal life
but the government first wants to get
rid of the sanctions
the problem is us is addicted to
sanctions
u.s is addicted to pressure u.s is
addicted to bullying
our sanctions the best bargaining chip
the us is addicted to bullying
it's hard to argue with that that's
certainly how it comes across and it has
for four years very loudly
to the point where there have been
actions taken you know the assassination
of
suleimani and uh you know these these
sorts of things do not play well uh in
iran and i think again it plays into the
hands of
the more hardline factions which are
it is very extreme it's very extreme
language but it's a language that is
used to speak to the people
on the ground yes whose lives now
a normal life is no longer possible
that's what we heard in that report is
that your
view of the situation is that how dire
it has become well certainly i i still
have some relatives who live there and
it's it definitely is very difficult
um made more difficult by the fact that
people weren't able to travel for those
who could travel you know for
for a long time so and with covid and
everything it's it's
but the iranians have also i think this
is something that's been going on for
them in terms of not being able to
to function normally you know having to
deal with sanctions not having
things available to them that's been
going on for more than a generation at
this point because sanctions are nothing
new
um and it's again i feel that it is
something that has
made the regime last as long as it did
it's never really had to answer for
uh the problems that exist the very real
problems that exist for you in iran
for people whether it's unemployment you
know inflation
uh just growing poverty growing
education at the same time which is
always very interesting that it's one of
the most educated
populations that you'll find certainly
in the middle east or
you know anywhere but but it's it's
something that
needs to be addressed and it would do
the us
administration well i think to try and
present a little bit of a different
image but it's a problem for joe biden
at home because
that is how the majority of americans
and including in the democratic party
think
they should be dealing with uh
conference what can you tell us about
uh the the lives of ordinary people
caught in the middle of this uh this
conflict well it's been as dire as as
the the clip has just shown um
and and it is also something where the
iranian population
uh for better for worse um has has
gotten used to the pandemic is coming on
top
uh but it's nothing that they should be
uh exposed to um
if only because uh the for for a long
time at least the
iran was complying with the nuclear deal
the the pull out of the united states
out of the nuclear deal the reimposition
of sanctions
was not justified by any policy moves if
you like uh
except for you know a change of heart uh
on the side of the
the us government whether the chain of
government obviously
but the problem with sanctions is that
they tend to be overestimated in what
they can achieve if you look at the
evidence of decades of economic
sanctions
they rarely work they are used as a
policy instrument to placate voters
to to show strength um to you know
try to follow a narrative of you know
putting someone down to their knees
but when has this happened uh ironically
the jcpa
with this concerted push is maybe the
one exception
where people realize okay it can work if
we
combine it with diplomacy and that's
what what was missing over the past four
years of the previous administration
any serious attempt to engage iran
or the the activities of iran at the
diplomatic level
so i'd be cautious as to what the
prospects of even more pressure can
achieve
daniel you're itching to get in well
sanctions are probably not directed
against against iran but
but but our tool to discipline everybody
else um
of course they have some sort of impact
on iran but of course they have a
stronger impact on the region
and they have a strong impact also on
the relationship between america and
europe
uh i think you're right cornelius it's
sanctions are being
overestimated but but lifting sanctions
is also being overestimated in terms of
an
economic benefit the iranian regime has
or the iranian government for that
matter has been has been promising of
course to the
iranian population that the nuclear deal
is going to bring foreign investment
it's going to bring bring
a prosperous economic development that
wasn't the case for a number of reasons
not only because iran cannot be iranian
economy cannot just be healed by by
foreign investment
but also by the fact that the companies
that could invest in iran that could
normalize the relationship
with iran are still scared to death
because they think
even if they don't violate any any law
uh
they might be at a later stage
sanctioned uh
by or affected by secondary sanctions by
the united states because they depend
the u.s control the financial sector
banks and so uh i think even if
we return to a nuclear deal we shouldn't
create false expectations in iran
uh the iranian economy is not going to
prosper because of that
because if you are a middle-sized
entrepreneur
in europe and you know that maybe in
four years
trump pompeo much more hardline than
trump much more uncompromising in terms
of iran
might return to power you uh you think
twice before you uh before you launch a
major investment
in iran and so therefore the iranian
government should should not
promise the iranian population that this
is all about the economy
the the the nuclear deal is a matter of
international security
uh but uh the economic economic
prosperity doesn't depend on this or not
sorry with your uh persian iranian roots
can you put
can you at the end of the show here we
don't have much time can you give us a
positive take on the future for
iran and iranians in the in the medium
term
well i think the dialogue is or the the
type of language that's been used uh
on the iranian part and the american
part will change i think it will be
softer and i think that's going to
present some hope
i agree that um lifting the sanctions is
not going to be
miracle cure but it's also something
that's going to hold the regime
feet to the fire they're going to have
to answer for why aren't things getting
better after they promised it and that's
that's a tool that works uh for the
united states as well so i think uh
things are somewhat positive but i'm i'm
not optimistic that the deal will be
struck
the very last word is there going to be
a nuclear deal between the two sides and
then in the coming months
well the deal is still there um we just
have three four months to to agree that
we still wanted to be alive
um i'm fairly optimistic that we will
get there okay
thanks very much indeed great debate uh
here on to the point uh
if you've enjoyed it as much as i have
do come back next time around until then
bye bye and cheers
[Music]
so
you